hello everyone its respondent on Alan's
birthday today and I thought it'd be a
nice idea to commemorate this occasion
by showing a very nice gem played
between him and the mad Titan vastly von
Schuch it's a game from 1988 it was
played in the Reggio Emilia tournament
in Italy which is the torneo de
capodanno in Italy it means the the
end-of-the-year tournament and it's it's
a tournament that has been played since
1958 and Rico poly started this
tradition italian grandmaster and ever
since then it's been played once a year
and it's really when they got a lot of
sponsors it became a bigger and bigger
tournament and then the the biggest one
was in the 1991 to 1992 array - Emilia
tournament were it was actually
Viswanathan Anand who won the tournament
ahead of Garry Kasparov Anatoly Karpov
and Vasily von Schuch who were really
insane players in those days but yeah
you remember perhaps perhaps you
remember those of you who have been
subscribed to this channel for some time
we've covered the 1991 Linares series by
vasily von Schuch were vastly one chick
who won that tournament a whole point a
head of garlic as part of but this game
today Alan the celebrates his 49th
birthday so not yet a 50 and here you
can see he tweeted a nice tweet about
this as everyone congratulated him in
there he showed some a nice drawing and
and a cake or or maybe it's two cakes I
think it's a one king cake but from
different perspectives so very nice and
like I said it's from 1988 both allant
and event took are 19 years old here and
they are they're of the same age only on
the birthdays today and event rock so in
my troops birthday was in March so
eventually is a bit older but you know
definitely a rivalry that that has
lasted for a lifetime and it's really an
insane game it's not the shortest game
on an island played in the Petrov
defense but it's a very nice one so
without further ado let's check out this
very nice game like we said it is the
batter of avant you opens with E for now
we have
'if I've Knight to f3 and Knight to f6
sorry about that night captures on e5 so
the classical variation of the patter of
defense these six nights to f3 we have
night captures on e4 d4 and d5 so this
is still the classical variation and
it's very interesting the classical
variation lasts for a very long time we
have a push up to d3 Bishop to e7
castles this is all standard book theory
or of the Petroff Knight to c6 rook to
e1 Bishop to g4 developing the light
square Bishop c3 now f5 here and here
Queen to b3
well while event tooks queen is on d1
you don't you you never want to capture
here and allow something like f captures
then you've created a very strong
component for all so you created a
semi-open F file you can't move the
knight maybe you want to attack this
night but the night is pinned so first
you have to move the Queen Queen to b3
by one choke this comes with an attack
against the b7 pawn but now Queen to d6
and now you don't want to capture on b7
if you capture Queen captures on b7 then
rook here Queen here and then the first
Bishop captures on f3 g captures and it
will be it will be a very hard position
to play for white after Queen to g6
black will create a very strong attack
now to create to defend the f2 pawn you
have to go to f1 and then it will be it
will be just a very unpleasant game for
white but ok that of course is still
part of theory so no one really captures
the b7 pawn but now comes Knight f2 d2
they're going after this night and as
the Queen is no longer on d1 so the
knight is no longer pinned but you never
want to capture this Knight that's not
the point you never want to allow F
captors only for the idea is here to
play f3 and force islands to capture on
D - that's the idea and ok we have
queenside castle by island and now comes
f3 and now it seems that even that arm
is forced to capture for example if you
play Knight captures here then you get
Bishop captures and after Bishop moves
Bishop will capture and f5 would check
and Ivanka will win upon here king b8 a
rook is coming to e6 and already White
is starting to create
something so after f3 Anand found the
best move in this position
Bishop to h4 although the rook is a very
deep in in White's camp it's also
undefended and the problem is you cannot
play g3 here to repel the bishop if you
play g3 here then you get best captures
H captures and Queen captures and
checkmate will follow either King F to
King F 1 followed by Queen to have to
checkmate or you can go King to h1 but
then Knight to f2 is checkmate so here
after Bishop to h4 eventually decided to
move the rook we look to f1 and here
again it seems like event you didn't
fall for it or however you want to
phrase it and it's still you either have
to move the bishop well you could
capture and still go for the same idea
Knight Bishop captures you move the
bishop and then again you lose the f5
pawn with check or there is a different
idea now after Luke to f1 you could move
the bishop immediately but then after
pawn captures and pawn captures yes you
have created a very strong passed pawn
here but here white can simply ignore
you and play Knight captures pawn
captures Bishop captures and white would
just be up upon with with a better
position so Anand doesn't like either of
these two choices and place the third
option which is Bishop to h3 and now
it's a very interesting position event
Chuck has a whole lot of options here he
can capture an h3 he didn't capture on
e4 but none of none of those work if you
capture on h3 Queen to g6 will be very
deadly Queen g6 check King has to move
then I discovering after you have to go
to h1 and now comes Knight to f2 check
you have to capture the knight rode
captures Bishop captures the threat is
now Queen to g1 checkmate and after
Queen 31 rook h d8 and there is no
defense against this row coming to you 1
you cannot block with the night which
would be pointless because then it's
again Queen to g1 checkmate and on the
other hand after Bishop to h3 if you
still insist on capturing the night it
still doesn't work because of the same
Queen to g6 threatening checkmate on g2
and after the roadblocks you will simply
capture it King capture screen captures
and after King to e1 now comes F
captures on e4
the rook is now coming to the F file and
it will be a swift victory for black
for example Bishop attacks Queen Queen
g1 pins the bishop Queen comes to help
out with the defense but rook is coming
to f8 Queen e2 but now
simply push up to g4 and the Queen has
no squares
however the Queen moves she issue will
be lost and if you play something like
Queen to g2 where the Queen can go but
then rocked after Sun if one is a mate
mate in five after Queen captures Queen
to b3 chair Queen blocks and now Queen
captures on e 2 will be checkmate so a
very unpleasant move this Bishop to h3
but if I took place the most precise
defense Queen to c2 preparing to move
the knight and from C to the Queen will
be protecting the G to pawn and okay we
have Queen to g6 Anand is not
threatening checkmate on g2 but now
Knight b3 the queen is not defending
white from being checkmated and here
rook h 2f 8 event troops successfully
defended now honored simply continues to
play the game normally the developing or
putting the rook on a nice F file and
here again if you insist on capturing
for example F captures on e4
you get pawn captures and now after you
move the bishop the bishop will still be
attacked and white will have to give up
the bishop if you move the bishop to a4
black can can't push be fine but it's it
doesn't make sense you can simply
capture and after King captures rook f8
and the game is over King g1 bishop you
have to check and now you will either
move the King and get checkmate it or
you will have to give up your queen so
everything everything loses here if
Queen if King - a wand and of Queen
captures King moves and now Bishop - for
checking D 1 and group 2 F 1 will be
checkmate so very nice but here if I
played nice to a3 and this is a very
interesting move for because of what if
on 2 plays next here on unplayed rook d
t8 so first rook H - f 8 and then rook
d2 e 8 and here something happened in
von Schuch said no one
probably can explain what perhaps they
had a discussion about it after the game
who knows
here event you played King to h1 but
hereafter for example you could have
played f chapters on e4 here it does
work because after you exchange you can
exchange a pair of rooks and after rook
captures Bishop to f1 and now there are
no tricks here the bishop is now
defending the g2 point here and the
bishop turf to check no longer works
because you can simply move the move the
king or even capture with the Queen now
once you've exchanged one pair of looks
after no capture skin captures g2 is
defended and the White will have
sufficient material to continue this
game on the other hand you could also
simply continue with Bishop to f4
continue developing and still black has
no real way of forcing matters here but
it once you've played King to h1 and
this is a move that loses the game on
the spot but feel free to pause the
video here and win this very nice game
for an ins 49th birthday so for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
exploiter of event troops mistakes and
for those who just want to enjoyed show
nice to have to check seems like a move
you you would play but you also have to
find the next move of course if you move
the king then the Queen captures and g2
will be checkmate but if you capture the
night rook if you capture with the Queen
of course you'll lose the Queen but the
fruit captures here's a word becomes
interesting and this is the move you had
to find not rook e1 you can simply block
with rook f1 but Bishop captures and g2
and it was in this position and move 18
that Vasili von Schuch resigned the game
why did he resign well the white king is
in check and you have to play something
if you capture it then you get rook to
e1 check and now the roof is no longer
on the F file you have to block on the G
file and now simply rook captures rook
will will be checkmate on the other hand
if you don't capture the bishop if you
move the King let's say you go King V 1
again it's the same idea
rook to e1 check and it's a forced
checkmate bunch of blocks but now comes
Luke captures rook captures and now the
King has no escape path you will simply
play bishop
actors on f3 and now the bishops are
doing all the work here you you can't
move with the King you have to block
either with the bishop but that's
pointless you have to give up the Queen
and then it's squink after some g2 again
a forced checkmate
so after Bishop captures in g2 even
should resign the game and the very nice
18 move gem against such a such a strong
Grandmaster such as Vasily Evangel but
it's interesting when I mentioned the FY
that knife to a three here a bunch of
white knight to a three why this this
was so interesting because here instead
of this Knights to a three it's possible
to clicking to h1 and it is in fact a
good move because there Allen still
didn't play rook d2 yeah look dt8 and
now there is no real threat of nice to
have to so here King to h1 would have
been a good move but here something
happened in von Schuch said he played
first Knight 2 a 3 and then after iron
plated he just thought ok Anand is
simply putting a rock around on a better
file I'll continue with my plan which
was king - h1 here we played King - h1
and the game is over but yeah yeah very
very very nicely done by both of them
and yeah I do hope you enjoyed this game
for Arnold's birthday and let me know if
you enjoyed the alpha 0 vs stockfish
games from from the new match if you
have and if you would like to see more
of them do share in the comments and you
know well you should always let me know
either in the comments or by liking the
video that's that's how I know we if you
like the content or if you don't like
the content or if you don't like it you
know just dislike it that that's
basically all I need to know whether
you're enjoying it or not so yeah I
would like to thank Mario and C knows
James cocoros
William Jones Arthur clay and Anton
lager for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos he are thankful for watching and
I will see you soon most likely with a
game from the London chest classic where
Fabiana Khurana has his chance today
against Hikaru Nakamura to overtake
Magnus Carlsen in the number one spot in
ratings but but only in the live ratings
not for real but you know first you have
to overtake him in live ratings only
then can you
Maria thank all for watching and I will
see you soon